[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur TVfil 78 si vous n rejoignez dans ce
nouveau numéro du 78 société ce soir
émission spéciale qui ne durera pas 30
minutes mais 1 heure elle portera sur
l'appel du 16 juin initiative citoyenne
portée par Mustapha boui président du
club de foot de l'Étoile Sportive de
trappe et également président de l'appel
le principe est simple fédérer les
associations et personnalités de trappe
pour mutualiser les forces vives du
territoire et assurer ainsi un suivi
extrascolaire des jeunes de la ville et
l'appel c'est un acronyme le a pour
association P personnalité passionné par
l'éducation et les loisirs n'hésitez pas
à réagir sur le Twitter de l'émission
ht78 société Patrice carmous bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous avez tenu à à
participer à cette émission vous allez
une d pourquoi d'abord ben merci de
m'accueillir dans dans ce C Nouradine
oui j'ai j'ai voulu parce que euh voilà
mustaapha a annoncé la création de cet
appel dans une émission qu'on fait
ensemble qui s'appelle PAF et et et
c'est vrai que moi ça m'a fasciné enfin
la la force avec laquelle il a lancé cet
appel ça s'est fait dans des
circonstances qui étit plutôt dramatique
je pense vous allez en rappeler mais
enfin mais c'est une vieille j'ai une
volonté plus ancienne de de de Mustapha
et je voudrais peut-être qu'il nous
raconte un peu la la jeunèse de de de
cet appel ben finalement l'émission va
durer une heure mais j'ai presque le
sentiment que vous avez tout dit et en
ce sens-là en ce sens-là en quelques
mots vous avez tout résumé à la fois
l'acronyme à la fois l'objet et en même
temps l'histoire et la genèse de de
cette association et c'est en ça que je
vrais vous remercier d'abord remercier
les téléspectateurs qui vont qui vont
être maintenant à l'écoute de ce qu'on
va pouvoir dire donc je je vous remercie
infiniment parce que ce dont on manque
le plus à mon sens dans les dans dans
nos territoires mais pas simplement ceux
de la banlieu mais dans les territoires
en général quand c'est quand il y a un
peu de désuvrement c'est la
reconnaissance d'un travail qui est fait
par un monde associatif bénévole par
excellence et donc cette reconnaissance
que vous offrez finalement je voudrais
être le porte-voix également de tous
ceux qui travaillent dans les
associations et pouvoir dire que la
reconnaissance existe elle passe par les
médias comme 78 le 78 d'aujourd'hui mais
également par Patrice qui est un un
excellent ambassadeur puisque j'ai eu
cette chance de pouvoir participer à la
fois à une émission de Paf mais
également à celle-ci pour pouvoir parler
de l'objet dont on va probablement aller
un peu plus dans le fond alors patri il
remettre les associations au cœur du
système quoi c'est ça voilà et et alors
les associations existent personne nen a
douté le club de foot existe depuis plus
de quasiment 80 ans maintenant il y a
d'autres associations qui fonctionnent
on sera entouré euh tout à l'heure
d'autres présidents d'association qui
eux ont répondu à l'appel déjà qu' on
répondu à l'appel ou d'autres
personnalités alors quand je parle de
personnalités je tiens à dire que ce
sont pas des personnalités connues
médiatisées pour moi les personnalités
sont les habitants de trap puisque ça ça
va se placer sur trap sur le territoire
de de trap c'est pour moi des
personnalités les personnalités de
trappe ne sont pas celles que l'on croit
ne sont pas seulement celles que l'on
croit des gens qui sont sur le terrain
c'est voilà voilà et pour moi les
personnalités c'est les personnes qui
sont sur le terrain et qui agissent
alors l'idée en réalité est très simple
Patrice le à l'instant c'est que d'une
part ça fait très longtemps que je
tourne autour de cette idée et puis il y
a des événements plus récents qui sont
marquantes qui sont déterminantes et qui
permet de dire souvent on a on dit
souvent plus jamais ça malheureusement
c'est pas le fait simplement de le dire
car la meilleure façon de dire c'est de
faire et en l'occurrence j'aimerais
qu'on appelle les associations les
personnalités de trappe les
personnalités qui sont autour de de de
cette de cette association d'association
ce groupement d'associations à nous
rejoindre pour une seule chose c'est
fabriquer encore plus d'outils pour être
utile et l'outil pour moi et le et
l'idée majeure de l'intelligence chez
l'homme c'est que un outil ça sert à
faire des effets leviers et appel va
justement procurer des outils avec un
objectif très très simple on l'a tous en
mémoire on l'a tous en tête l'enfant les
jeunes et bien c'est vraiment vers cet
objectif contendra c'est tous les outils
seront utiles à nos associations pour
faire en sorte que l'enfant soit mieux
accompagné dans son parcours culturel ou
sportif mieux accompagné dans la ville
et que alors j'ai cette formule si un
enfant quitte une de nos structures je
ne voudrais pas qu'il se dstructure bien
évidemment a tous les guillemets qu'on
met devant dstructurés souvent c'est un
problème de connaissance de tout ce qui
est possible de faire sur le territoire
c'est problème d'accompagnement voilà
tout est possible si les adultes
continue à accompagner et enfin pour
terminer voilà je j'agis sur le mononde
associatif depuis plus de 30 ans
maintenant dans les banlieu pour y être
né pour y avoir participé les banlieux
qui sont et les quartiers qui sont
autour de chez nous et voilà
aujourd'hui le citoyen que je suis
puisque c'est un peu la définition que
j'en ai c'est celui qui se réalise parce
qu'on a besoin de se réaliser avant tout
devenir celui qu'on doit être et se
sublimer pour être au service d'un
collectif voilà je j'ai une profession
la santé pour le moment un entourage et
et se sublimer c'est être citoyen et et
être citoyen c'est aussi faire appel aux
autres et j'en appelle donc à toutes les
personnes de bonne volonté au président
d'association à toutes les personnes V
nous rejoindre pour encore une fois
créer des outils ce n'est que le
début en tout cas merci
Patrice parce que c'est vrai qu'il faut
un travail formidable sur le terrain il
y a dans ces association ce qu'on
appelle des éducateurs et les éducateurs
ça veut dire l'éducation ils vont parler
beaucoup mieux que moi euh tous ces
présidents d'association qui sont là qui
ont répondu à l'appel de Mustapha et je
crois que c'est important de c'était
important de lancer cet appel c'est
important que les gens l'écoutent et et
vous rejoignent évidemment magnifique
merci en tout cas Moustapha et Patrice
un des éléments qui a été déclencheur
certainement pour vous Moustapha c'est
la mort du jeune Moussa ça a
certainement fait accélérer ce processus
je vous propose de revoir un reportage
qu'on avait fait sur la marche blanche
qui avait suivi justement ce décès
tragique de
Moussa des roses blanche à la main
malgré la pluie un long cortège de 2000
personnes dans les rues de Trab jusqu'au
squir Camu où Moussa 14 ans est tombé
sous les balles le 1er mai dernier un
cortège encadré par des membres du
service jeunesse en gilets jaunes des
banderoles qui réclam une paix sociale
dignité et émotion le départ a été donné
de la place des Merisiers devant la
famille les amis les proches à leur côté
des politique de gauche comme de droite
pas de discours pas de mots juste une
envie de comprendre pour que cela cesse
vivement qu'on trouve qui a tué ce gosse
on trouvera parce que c'est pas possible
de laisser dans l'irresponsabilité
l'assassinat d'un gamin de 14 ans c'est
pas possible qui qui était un un gamin
adorable quoi vraiment moi quand j'ai
appris quand j'ai appris sa mort je le
dis
tranquillement malgré mon âge mon
expérience j'ai pleuré parce que
c'était untit bonhomme comment on
devrait en avoir tous comme comme enfant
dans la vie dans la foule certains
collectaient des fonds au profit de la
famille pour les aider à financer les
funéraill au Mali j'ai fait le tour de
voir tout le monde que tout le monde
participe mettre une pièce là quand même
on a eu des personnes qui ont été
généreus qui ont mis des billets de 50 €
20 € donc c'est une bonne chose et moi
aussi j'appelle de tous mes vœux pour
que ce qu'on vient de vivre là que ça ne
recommence plus que cette marche serve à
quelque chose le long cortège a terminé
sa marche sir Camu douleur d'une famille
dépôt de fleurs et un message pour le
petit soldat Moussa parti au Paradis
recueillement demandé pour tous si les
journalistes veulent respecter la
souffrance de la famille et fermer leant
n rend serv c'est une belle initiative
parce que on voit aujourd'hui tous les
trapistes il n a pas des communautaires
par que tous les traapites qui sont à
vivre à TR aujourd'hui ils sont là la
solennité et les questionnements aussi
l'enfant du quartier ne doit pas être
mort pour rien disent certains qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour changer ça qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour les jeunes les habitants
de de Camu pas de travail pas d'emploi V
vraiment à Hu clos donc j'espère que que
l'électrochoc aura lieu finalement un
réel électrochoc et que ça changera et
que ça bougera tu peux mettre la police
tu peux mettre des hélicoptères tu peux
mettre tout ce que tu veux ça ça
n'arrangera pas le vivre ensemble
comment d'un quartier à l'autre on se
respecte et on se dit bonjour en
traversant la rue voilà bah il faut
faire des choses ensemble et ça ça se fe
par le sport par la culture je crois
encore à ça la mort de Moussa reste
encore inexpliquée conflit entre
quartiers ou guerre de territoire sur
fond de trafic de stupéfiant à trpequir
Camu et ailleurs dans la commune il y
aura un avant et un après
Moussa nous on rejoint sur le plateau du
78 société quatre invités qui ont
répondu à l'appel de Moustapha Larbaoui
on commence avec Sébastien Miguel
bonsoir vous êtes secrétaire de laadlt
c'est l'association des locataires de
trappe exact nous avons également Benoît
Cordin qui est secrétaire de
l'association donc appel et ancien
président de comité de quartier à Trapp
bonsoir bonsoir Jonathan Sorel président
de la section taekwendo du bchido club
de traape la structure qui devendra à
rentrere indépendant vous pourrez en
dire un mot tout à l'heure et qui
deviendra donc l'école de taekendo de la
ville bonsoir bonsoir et enfin Albert
Joseph Eugène Titus président de
l'association interculturelle mémoire et
tradition du monde et également et
surtout habitant de TR bonsoir bonsoir
alors on va peut-être commencer par une
réaction messieur sur ce qui s'est euh
sur ce qui a été diffusé à l'instant sur
la marche blanche Mustapha lbou vous
soutiez réagir sur les nombreuses
réactions des habitants de trappe et
environ alors il y a a il y a deux
choses dans le reportage qui m'ont que
j'ai revu parce qu'on c'est j'ai entendu
papi je crois dire
dein réagissons ensemble agissons
ensemble voilà appel n'est juste que
l'expression de ce qui a été dit durant
cette marche mais qui est dit en réalité
depuis très longtemps il y a beaucoup de
présidents qui sont isolés dans leur
association qui font un travail
remarquable encore une fois sur leur
objet mais qui travaill isolément pour
histoire isolé dans les moyens isolé
dans la construction et le vivre
ensemble c'est également agir tout
simplement ensemble donc ça a été dit
dans le reportage de la même façon je
voudrais réagir sur une deuxième chose
c'est qu'on a vu les politiques on a vu
le maire on a vu les députés on a vu
madame PC on a vu des députés on a vu
des personnes é de la la casquille et
c'est bien qu'on soit tous réunis ce
jour-là simplement je vrais que ça qu'on
perpétue cette marche mais qu'on marche
plus dans nos têtes simplement mais
qu'on marche réellement vers des
objectifs communs ceux que appel
voudrait fixer donc c'est un appel à
perpétuer cette marche à perpétuer le
mouvement pour se réunir et créer des
outils encore une fois j'essaie de très
très très pragmatique pour revenir sur
cette idée que on a besoin il y a besoin
de créer des moyens et parfois même on
peut faire mieux malgré les de de
subvention on parlera probablement tout
à l'heure mais al c'est ces deux points
là sur lesquels je vis réagir et le
dernier point c'est que concernant
Moussa qui est un qui est un enfant je
continue à dire il est un enfant du club
ou qui est passé par le club de trappe
pass TR mais pas simplement il y a
également Daoua qui a pris une balle
dans la jambe et puis ceux qui étaient
avec lui qui ont eu la déflagration tous
ces gens-là donc ont été marqués alors
c'est pas le facteur déclenchant d'appel
puisque ça fait 6 ans que ça que que que
que j'y pense simplement à un moment
donné c'est voilà ça suffit il y a des
éléments tragiques appel ne va pas
empêcher tout ce qui doit s'empêcher
simplement par définition
appelle pardon permettra des choses de
ne pas se produire on en saura jamais
mais au moins faisons-le pour que ça
n'arrive pas et et c'est en ça que il y
a quelque chose que j'aais relevé qu'on
a dit tout à l'heure c'est que ce gosse
était gentil il y avait pas plus
adorable il y avait pas plus gentil
souvent sémin par les amis les proches
et j'ai pas souhaité m'exprimer son le
moment on m'a pas vu sur les plateaux on
m'a pas vu en caméra dans ces moments de
de de recueillement de dignité j'étais
dans la marche avec les gens du club
simplement jeaais quand même relevé une
chose c'est que il aurait pu être autant
garnement qu'un enfant peut l'être à son
âge c'est pas pour autant que ce meurtre
ce crime horrible n'aurait pas été moins
crapuleux donc il était mignon il était
adorable il était travailleur oui mais
il aurait été un tout petit peu
différent de ça que pour autant donc
c'est tous les jeunes qui m' les gentils
et les moins gentils et enfin pour
terminer j'ai jamais eu un problème avec
un seul gosse sur sur la commune de tram
jamais jamais globalement on en parlera
peut-être plus tard mais c'est plutôt
avec les adultes qu'on doit
travailler je vais vous poser la
première question messieur autour de la
table qu'est-ce qui vous a convaincu
vous dans dans le discours de de
Mustapha pourquoi vous avez eu envie de
rejoindre cette association l'appel ben
Cordin peut-être pour commencer dans un
premier temps j'ai rejoint cette
association parce que Mustapha qui est
quelqu'un que je connais depuis
maintenant 7 8 ans de par les comités de
chartiers où il a fait il m'a fait le
plaisir de venir participer à plusieurs
de mes réunions m'a fait une demande
tout simplement parce que on a nous tous
ici autour de la table une expertise en
tout cas une connaissance du terrain de
trapppe de ses habitants chacun à un
notre niveau chacun avec notre culture
aussi moi j'ai pas forcément la culture
de la majorité de la population de trape
mais j'ai un regard un petit peu
extérieur je suis arrivé à trape en an
2000 pas avant mais ça m'a donné aussi
cette cette ce recul par rapport à la
population et cette envie aussi de
participer à les for nécessaire pour
faire en sorte que trappe devienne une
ville comme les autres que les habitants
de trappe soient des enfants comme les
autres et qu'on puisse enfin sortir de
cette espèce de moule que dans lequel on
est enfmé enfermé depuis des années des
années qui font que les enfants de trap
sont toujours des enfants avec un passif
à porter qui est quelque chose
d'absolument insupportable donc j'ai eu
la chance par les comités de quartiers
de découvrir de nombreux habitants j'ai
eu la chance par le taekwondo puisque je
me suis occupé aussi du club pendant
quelques années de découvrir de nombreux
enfants de la ville et ça n'aqu été que
du bonheur voilà c'est c'est une qui est
riche d'une diversité d'une expérience
d'une vivacité incroyable qu'on retrouve
peut-être pas beaucoup ailleurs et appel
comme nous l' présenter Mustapha aura
vraiment cette fonction de d'aller vers
les autres de les aider de les guider de
mieux les guider peut-être que ce n'est
fait jusqu'à présent et de mettre en
relation toutes les forces vives qu'on
peut retrouver sur le terrain on fait fi
de tout ce qui est politique on fait fit
de tout ça et on se ressaisit tous
ensemble on a eu des événement
dernièrement que ça soit au mois de
janvier ou que ça soit dernièrement avec
le l'assassineousa voilà il y a un
moment donné où effectivement faut que
faut qu'on avance et on peut-être les
politiques nous rejoindront un jour et
pourquoi pas peu importe mais en tout
cas là on va être tous ensemble
habitant les personnes qui vivent et qui
exploitent cette ville qui se
développent là et qui ont envie de faire
en sorte que trap soit une ville
parfaite on reviendra sur le rôle des
politiques tout à l'heure Sébastien
Miguel enchanté heureux d'être ici en
tout cas et de pouvoir participer un
petit peu à cette à cette à cet
événement qui pour moi on va être assez
intéressant dans un contexte qui est un
petit peu différent puis que moi je on
n'est pas issu du côté on va dire
sportif mais plutôt dans une association
qui diffère où on est plutôt dans une
défense de
locataires pas contre on espère avec
mais en l'occurrence actuellement c'est
plutôt contre avec des
bailleurs sociaux qui sont actuellement
sur trappe et voilà on s'est investi
dans ce sens depuis quelques années euh
beaucoup d'explosions puisque il faut
savoir qu'il y a énormément de choses
qui ne vont pas attrape au niveau des
logements qui sont pas pris en compte et
cetera euh et dans ce sens justement
monsieur laboui justement nous a permis
de pouvoir avancer et de se dire que il
y a autre chose à faire que de rester
comme il a si bien dit dans notre coin
et de pouvoir on va dire donner une
synergie dans notre manière de
fonctionner et d'avancer différemment
aujourd'hui on a certes des solutions
chacun de notre côté aujourd'hui on va
pouvoir essayer de les mutualiser de
façon à ce qu'on puisse tous en profiter
nous aujourd'hui on a la possibilité de
toucher plus de 3000 personnes en terme
d'habitation et même plus encore donc ce
qui nous permet d'avoir on va dire un
audit et une possibilité de pouvoir se
faire entendre différemment que celle
que du côté sportif qui était on va dire
un petit peu différent donc voilà on y
apporte notre soutien notre volonté et
notre manière de travailler et puis
notre notre engouement à vouloir on va
dire essayer de changer les choses un
petit peu à trrape Albert
tius
bonsoir merci tvfield de de nous
accueillir et merci à Monsieur l'arbaoui
que je connais depuis plus de 10 ans ça
fait un bon moment que je le côtoie et
monsieur laaboui a un dynamisme et une
humilité qui ne fait pas apparaître tout
ce qu'il apporte et j'ai eu l'occasion
avant de commencer l'émission d'être
avec lui tout à l'heure dans la rue il y
a un monsieur qui l'aborde dit je vous
ai vu à la télé je vous ai vu à la télé
mais vous savez vous êtes très très très
connu et il en était tout ému tout ému
monsieurboui dans sa démarche et veut
rassembler avec lui des des des gens je
peux dire humblement des personnalités
et autres qui ont la capacité de
participer activement à son désir à
c'est-à-dire eu apporter aux habitants
de de trappes et pas seulement de trappe
des ivelines et et d'ailleurs puisqu'on
l'a vu dans d'autres émissions qui qui
déparche largement le cadre de de notre
département de d'apporter et un
changement un un changement je peux dire
que son appel c'est l'appel du 16 juin
hein il y a CELI du 18 juin il y a
l'appel du 16 juin et c'est cet appel
c'est à ce que tout le monde soit un peu
plus
responsabilisé pour pouvoir apporter à
toutes les populations toutes les
couches de population autre chose que
cette avenir qui nous semble moruse
Jonathan Sorel pour terminer ce premier
tour de table ou bonsoir continuer hein
du coup moi je vais prêcher un peu pour
ma paroisse c'est vrai que comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure le taekwendo
sur le bchido club de traap ça se
termine d'ailleurs la saison est
terminée et on très belle saison
parenthèse une très très belle saison je
suis vraiment fier de toutes les
personnes qui m'entourent tant les
enseignants que les enfants on a eu un
champion de France Yanis Gomis qui j'ai
appris ce matin est préqualifié pour les
championnats du monde ah donc je croise
les doigts pour lui je le félicite et je
suis vraiment vraiment très fier de
faire partie de cette aventure avec eux
d'où le projet en fait de de prendre
notre indépendance et d'ouvrir notre
club comme vous l'avez dit donc école
tawend trap école pourquoi parce qu'on
pense que vraiment il y a la partie
loisir mais il y a un réel apprentissage
et c'est là que je rejoins un peu l'idée
de mustaapha qui est vraiment de cadrer
les jeunes un maximum les
les les laisser dans nos structures
essayer de faire un maximum de choses et
que ça dépasse même le cadre de du sport
c'est-à-dire vraiment qu'on puisse les
aider tant sur leur vie personnelle que
sur leur vie profane quand ils seront un
peu plus grand ou leur vie à l'école
essayer de les diriger les driver sur ce
qu'on peut leur apporter et je pense que
justement appel va pouvoir nous
permettre comme l'a dit aussi Sébastien
de mutualiser nos efforts essayer de
réfléchir tous ensemble savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on peut apporter de de différent
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire
pour faciliter un peu le leur vie sur la
commune et leur vie dans la en règle
générale mais on va rentrer dans le vif
du sujet concrètement comment appel va
agir sur le terrain qu'est-ce qui va
être fait concrètement avec cette
association c'est vrai que d'abord je
voudrais quand même aussi les remercier
ceux qui sont présents et à travers leur
témoignage remercier tous ceux qui nous
ont rejoint déjà car il n'y a pas
simplement ceux qui sont sur le plateau
aujourd'hui qui nous ont rejoint
jeaurais parler de on parle
d'association sportive mais également
d'association culturelle et de
personnalités qui sont pas forcément ni
président ni dans les associations et
puis on a même on a on a vu des gens qui
gèrent on va dire les habitants et leur
mode de vie dans leur logement alors
donc vous couvrez une partie importante
quand même de la population trapiste
avec toutes ces associations pour le
moment on peut déjà dire qu'on couvre la
totalité par échantillonnage on couvre
la totalité parce que culturelle est
sportive les locataires mais également
des gens de la société civile comme on
les appelle qui sont à la fac de
cquentin qui sont euh dans d'autres
professions ça fait combien
d'associations à peu près là qui vous
ont rejoint déjà alors je on a un petit
chiffre ouais je vais vous le donner je
vais vous donner des chiffres parce que
j'aime le concret je je pense que
d'ailleurs cette association va se bâtir
sur du concret et apportera des
solutions concrètes pas simplement le
discours d'aujourd'hui mais un appel par
définition il se proclame donc on
proclame aujourd'hui et demain on
apportera des outils réels et sérieux
avec des chiffres euh pour le coup je
vais vous en donner mais euh juste un
mot pour pour nos téléspectateurs c'est
que euh voilà les associations qui
existent ici font un travail remarquable
déjà euh sans sans appel sans appel ils
seraiit ils sont dans leur objet
uniquement dans leur objet simplement
dans tout ce qu'ils font il y a un
élément qui les transcende c'est pas
simplement l'objet sport ou la culture
mais il y a également cette l'idée de
vivre ensemble et de faire ensemble et
c'est à ça que j'ai voulu répondre et ça
fait longtemps que que j'y pensais euh
ça c'est le premier point et le second
point j'ai moi-même mes pères c'està
dire que moi-même si aujourd'hui je
lance appelle aujourd'hui en réalité
c'est une expérience mais c'est
également des gens qui m'ont transmis
des valeurs je vais rendre hommage ici à
des gens comme Jean gemmat que
probablement tout le monde connaît de
black blamber qui nous a rejoint de
Déclic Théâtre qui nous ont rejoint mais
également
mououulin qui a fait un très très gros
travail à l'époque d'improvisation
théâtrale mais également qui est à bloc
blamberur aujourd'hui mes pères
m'avaient appris une chose quand j'étais
euh jeune pour le coup moins jeune on va
dire dans les dans les territoires un
peu complexes un peu difficiles un peu
désœuvrés dshérités prenons le mot qu'on
veut peu importe on sait de quoi on
parle de toute façon mais euh je
trouvais et et ils avaient compris à
l'époque je parle de ces de mes pères
que on dépensait beaucoup à occuper les
gamins on dépensait probablement trop
dans la consommation
d'où l'étonnement peut-être de voir
loisir dans votre appel parce que le l
c'est loisir je vais justement pour le
coup vous en parler c'est que on a
toujours compris eux en premier lieu moi
je l'ai ressenti comme ça et je le je le
vis maintenant le loisir n'est qu'un
prétexte simplement au lieu de dire dans
les associations petit petit petit viens
jouer au foot on te donne la babal et on
va l'occuper et tu vas te faire plaisir
j'ai presque le sentiment qu'on en est
que c'est quasi manipulatoire on vous
faire quoi à des enfants qui sont là que
pour s'amuser oui il faut qu'ils
s'amusent oui il faut qu'ils prennent du
plaisir et on appr prend avec eux à
jouer à transformer des buts à
transformer des objectifs simplement
nous on sait on sait que ça a une valeur
éducative on sait que ça fait
grandir la conscience voir la
construction de la sensibilité à vivre
ensemble nous on le sait adulte
simplement moi par exemple dans le club
de foot de trappe je le dis c'est pas
simplement un loisir festif un loisir de
consommation simplement un loisir pour
mais il y a réellement quelque chose
d'éducatif et quand ils l'entendent les
enfants plus tôt ils l'entendent plus il
l'acceptent d'ailleurs ils acceptent non
seulement la discipline on a parlé tout
à l'heure il y a quelqu'un qui a évoqué
la notion de discipline mais c'est pas
la discipline c'est pas simplement je
veux voir qu'une tête je veux voir qu'un
rang je veux voir chacun au garde à vous
mais la discipline c'est comment on gère
un collectif comment ensemble je vais
finir làdessus je va en finir làdessus
parce que c'est important
la discipline dans les banlieux il y en
a plus qu'ailleurs on veut faire croire
que dans les banlieux il y a pas de
discipline que la République ne rentre
pas et ca probablement qu'il y a des
difficultés mais pas cette idée de
discipline probablement pas celle qu'on
voudrait mais dans nos associations par
le loisir alors on fait passer ces
notions de respect d'autruit de respect
de de l'engagement et ça il y en a il y
en a plus que partout ailleurs je le
sais parce que sinon ça tiendrait pas
dans les banlieux s'il pas une certaine
discipline auquel cas travaillons à
faire en en sorte que voilà tout ça soit
remis à sa place alors justement
concrètement ça va donner quoi Mustapha
sur le terrain d'abord combien
d'associations vous ont rejoint pour
l'instant ave personnalité par soyons
concret les les téléspectateurs en
conviendront c'est que j'ai pas pu
appeler les 350 associations de trappe
pour dire on commence sinon je
commençais jamais il y a un métier il y
a une occupation qui fait qu'on peut pas
appeler tout le monde j'ai donc fait
appel vous l'avez entendu à des gens qui
sont autour de du club de foot ou ma
personne donc j'ai fait appel proche
pour l'instant un premier cercle tout
simplementésente combien 20 30 allez on
a on a on a fait tout à l'heure un peu
allusion
au au 16 juin pour ne pas dire au 18
juin et donc j'ai pas voulu le faire le
18 juin c'était possible c'était même
facile mais j'ai trop trop de respect
encore une fois le respect de la mémoire
le respect historique le respect du
général on le fera pas le 18 juin pour
le coup mais c'est un hommage que je
rends parce qu'à l'époque ça part d'un
constat le constat l'a fait depuis 30
ans tout le monde parle plus jamais ça
il faut plus qu'on revoie ça tout le
monde le dit travaillons ensemble
faisons-le et comme le général il a
commencé avec un noyau un premier cercle
et il y aura un deuxème cercle il aura
je comprends bien mustaphaar un premier
cercle on aura peut-être bientôt un
chiffre mais donc il a un PR je le donne
il y a maintenant jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui répertorié sur le sur le
dernier PV parce que encore une fois
c'est pas simplement un appel de ce jour
mais on a déjà beaucoup travaillé on
s'est vu à plusieurs reprises pour
construire l'objet c'estàd se mettre
d'accord sur la philosophie se mettre
d'accord sur la
terminologie pour pouvoir en parler
maintenant mais également écrire les
statut donc notre secrétaire ici donc on
a beaucoup travaillé des chif vous en
voulez bah jusqu'à maintenant il y a 20
associations déjà regroupé alors je peux
les citer par exemple tout le monde
connaît l'OMS qui nous a rejo municipal
des sports la gymnastique gymnique nous
ont rejoint donc on a vu le
taekwendo donc le football mais
également Déclic Théâtre mais également
black blamber mais également
probablement que j'en oublie alors des
associations comme la la DLT je confonds
toujours la DLT mais également notre
ami Titus qui va nous rappeler son
association association c'est
l'association interculturelle mémoire et
tradition du monde voilà avec toutes les
on va pas tous les citer ah je voulais
des chiffres donc j'en ai à peu près une
vingtaine si vous avez du temps devant
vous je vais tous les citer il y en a
beaucoup et c'est un premier cercle
comme a pu le faire quelqu'un qui a mis
en place une stratégie on commence
toujour avec un noyau et de façon
concentrique et de façon voilà donc euh
sur le terrain comment vous allez vous
organiser concrètement c'est une
plateforme qui va regrouper ces
associations ensuite pour faire quoi
concrètement alors c'est une association
donc elle a un président on m'a fait
l'honneur de de me laisser cette
présidence pas simplement un honneur je
le dis tout de suite mais une
responsabilité au regard de ce que
j'entends dans la bouche des des gens
qui nous ont rejoint je je je je ressens
plus ça avance plus je ressens le poids
des responsabilités et et Titus le
disait tout à l'heure c'est des gens
responsables dont j'ai besoin c'est des
gens qui agissent qui prennent leur
responsabilité et qui vont au fond des
choses concrètement on a créé une
association concrètement un on va se
réunir très régulièrement je le dis 3e
mercredi de chaque mois en un lieu que
nous seuls connaissons pour le moment
mais probablement que quand on le on le
fera connaître à d'autres il nous
rejoindront et on étendra le lieu tous
les 3è mercredi moi donc c'est pas une
conversation qu'on a eu et une idée
subtile géniale simplement avec un un un
logo à ce propos on a déjà travaillé sur
le logo donc en quelques jours il y a un
logo qui est sorti il y a une
organisation qui est sortie donc
structurer en association donc une ré
construire quoi on a déjà un agenda pour
construire quoi pour construire encore
une fois la mutualisation donc il va y
avoir à faire tout un inventaire de ce
qui se passe dans chaque association de
l'inventaire naîtra des petits
dénominateurs communs ouais et j'espère
demain le commun fera fera l'essentiel
de tous ce que moi je fais au club de
foot j'aimerais que ça soit partager
pour certains
points et on pourra en parler dans les
autres associations ce qui se passe dans
les associations ce qui se passe au
travers des des gens qui produisent dans
leur encore une fois dans leurs
activités il y a à faire un inventaire
c'est un gros boulot il y a à
proposer faire en sorte que des outils
qui dans chaque association puissent
être utilisés mais l'idée encore une
fois c'est ça c'estis il y a une
mutualisation des idées il y a partager
il y a échanger rien que ça le S tank
peut se suffire à lui-même je suis plus
tank je suis plus tank que Sy et cette
phrase de ronchard qui dit agir en
primitif raisonner en stratège alors on
a fait le constat on a réfléchi on sait
ce qu'il faut faire on sait qu'il faut
être sur le terrain trouver des outils
par exemple j'en donne un tout de suite
voilà un exemple au club de foot alors
la référence c'est le club de foot
puisque on a mis en place des outils et
la référence sera seront également les
autres associations un un outil très
simple plus de 1089 personnes se sont
inscrites pour club de foot l'INC donc
des chiffres vous en vouliez l'INC nous
annonce que plus de 20 % des garçons de
trappe sont au club de foot de trappe
plus de 20 % un enfant un garçon sur 5
de 6 à 19 ans exactement de 6 à 19 ans
20 % sauf que quand on le ramène aux
enfants qui font une activité c'estàd ou
du sport ou de la culture alors on passe
à 30 % le pourcentage augmente et quand
on sait qu'on avait pas la place
physiquement pour faire rentrer les
féminines à ce propos on aurait dû avoir
une présence féminine mais pour un
problème
d'organisation l'une d'entre elles n'a
pas pu venir au passage mais les
féminines au foot ça va grandir donc
globalement le club de foot va jusqu'à
35 40 % des enfants de trappp je me
rends compte que allez pourquoi est-ce
que tout le monde voudrait faire du fout
si ce n'est que c'est culturel peut-être
que c'est un réflexe peut-être que c'est
allez le sens inné des choses sauf que
moi ma crainte c'est que quand quelqu'un
se dit mais finalement j'ai fait du foot
parce que parce que parce que mais en
réité c'est pas ça je voudrais surtout
pas qu'il quitte ma structure et qu' se
déstructure donc l'idée de mettre en
place des passerelles c'est très simple
il existe le carnet de santé il existe
le livret scolaire il existera demain
allant l'avait appelé le passeport chez
nous il s'appellera probablement le
sésame le carnet éducatif de suivi donc
pour toute l'association
ou tous et et ce Carnel j'espère qu'il
sera proposé à d'autres et chacun dira
il fait ça mais peut-être qu'il pourrait
faire ça aussi et il y aura un conseil
d'orientation il y aura voilà ce suivi
cet accompagnement voilà j'arrête de
parler on va demandé autour de la table
qu'est-ce que vous attendez vous
concrètement de cette association là il
y a déjà une remarque que l'on peut
faire déjà de base à ce niveau-là c'est
que lorsqu'il y a eu l'appel qui a été
fait par Mustapha Larbaoui nous-même on
a même été très très très étonné c'est
la première c'est le nombre de personnes
auxquelles ont répondu à cet appel ouis
euh de manière spontanée et de manière
franche et sincère ce qui veut dire
qu'en réalité il y a un vrai travail de
fond à faire et une vraie volonté et un
enthousiasme réel donc de ce fait il y a
vraiment on va dire il y a il y a des
armes il y a des au sens propre au sens
Figur Figur pardon propre excusez-moi
euh donc de pouvoir on va dire avancer
et et cette volonté là on va pouvoir
l'utiliser cette muttilisation je pense
sincèrement qu'elle peut être utile que
ça soit on va dire pour défendre des
locataires nous à notre niveau on va
pouvoir avancer pour propager on va dire
des informations ça va être un rôle
essentiel en tout cas je l'espère
puisqu'on touche énormément en terme de
population lorsque nous on s'est fait
élire au niveau de la DLT en tant que
représentant des locataires on a quand
même touché plus de 3500 logements à
mettre dans les boîes au lettres et
cetera on l'a fait à deux trois reprises
comme ça ce qui veut dire qu'on avait
déjà un travail de fond une certaine
organisation de notre manière de
travailler on continue d'évoluer dans ce
sens euh donc pour moi je pense
sincèrement que en regardant donc
l'école de techmondo que ça soit soit le
côté culturel aussi de la même façon que
ça soit aussi donc locataire et autres
je pense sincèrement qu'il y a de vrais
efforts aujourd'hui moi ce que je
constate c'est qu'il y a des gens des
personnalités qu' ont vraiment envie de
faire bouger les choses à traape arrêtez
de parce que moi ça fait je j'ai habité
à traape je suis reparti de trappe je
suis revenu à trappe j'étais à l'école à
trappe je j'ai fait du sport à trappe
donc ça fait que je connais quand même
assez bien aujourd'hui j'y habite aussi
de ce fait le vrai constat qu'on peut
ressortir c'est qu'il y a des vraies
volontés il serait temps de pouvoir
faire en sor h ona et derrière on avance
mais de manière structurée ce qui nous
changerait du coup ben Cordin comment on
va faire quand un je sais pas un gamin
qui est au club de taekwendo qui va
quitter le club comment on va faire pour
le suivre est-ce que ça va être j'ai
envie de j'ai fait utiliser le mot ça va
être du flicage ou comment ça va être
concrètement et ben pourquoi pas à vrai
dire est-ce que c'est vraiment si grave
de que ça que ce soit du flicage
l'essentiel étant qu'à un moment donné
chaque enfant qu'il fasse telle ou telle
activité ne soit pas à un moment donné
parce qu'il y a un problème personnel
familial ou un manque de d'appétence
pour pour l'activité qui lui est proposé
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il ne soit pas
lâché dans la nature et qu'elle se
retrouve devant sa console de jeu en bas
de son immeuble et là c'est un enfant
qui est sportivement peut-être perdu
mais peut-être aussi au niveau de social
au niveau éducatif perdu un petit peu
parce comme l'a dit Mustapha l'école je
suis enseignant donc ça va m'aider
d'autant plus mais l'école est quand
même un vecteur éducatif important et un
des vecteurs de développement social et
et de d'amélioration en tout cas de de
de la capacité à s'intégrer dans une
société
mais le sport est également les
activités culturelles sont également et
un enfant qui se perd dans le football
qui se perd dans le Tyo dans le tennis
dans la gym et ben peut-être qu'en
travaillant avec cet enfant en discutant
avec lui parce que le chaque responsable
associatif va pas laisser partir la
personne sans sans faire attention donc
oui on va fliquer la présence ou
l'absence des enfants à chacune de nos
séances et c'est de notre responsabilité
d'organisateur et de gestionnaire d'une
d'un club donc on va les suivre et puis
peut-être que par le dialogue on va se
rendre compte que cet individu là
peut-être qu'on pourrait le guider vers
des associations peut-être plus cultur
de la musique les associations
l'association de Titus l'association
black bomber il y a une diversité
d'offres sur trappp qui est absolument
plétorique chacun doit trouver sa place
en tout cas personne ne doit rester sur
le côté cha alors un enfant qui désirera
rester tout seul devant sa console de
jeu pourquoi pas à vra dire on peut pas
l'empêcher on peut pas le forcer à faire
mais ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il ne soit
pas devant sa console par défaut
d'autrre chose faut qu'il soit devant sa
console parce que c'est un choix nous
notre responsabilité de responsable
associatif de connaisseurs de la ville
ça va de lui proposer l'intégralité du
panel de discuter avec lui de dialoguer
avec lui a vous nouveau conseil
d'orientation en quelque sorte et ben
au-delà de l'établissement scolaire
pourquoi pas ça c'est un premier point
après comme disait Mustapha tout ce qui
va être mutualisation des savoirs des
acquis des compétences de chacune des
associations va se faire forcément au
bénéfice des des enfants des pratiquants
enfants et adultes d'ailleurs donc il y
a vraiment derrière cette notion d'appel
la reconstruction d'un nouveau tissu
associatif et social sur traap et c'est
ça la richesse de ce projet de Mustapha
donc il faut absolument qu'on soit là et
qu'on y participe activement et du coup
pourquoi s'arrêter à traape pourqu par
qu'il faut commencer à un moment donné
sur un territoire petit peu restreint
que l'on connaît et bien évidemment si
l'expérience sur trap fonctionne et
c'est l'ambition mustaapha ce projet ce
schéma qu'on est en train de mettre en
place devra s'ouvrir ailleurs tout en
sachant que de base excusant c'est que à
la de fait on est déjà en dehors de
trappe de base ne serait-ce que notre
association déjà elle est trappe et en
dehors de trappe puisque notre
représentation c'est on va dire s an sur
Guillon courour c'estends sur Manamo
c'est an sur d'autres V qui font
qu'automatiquement on touche aussi d'
personnes pour ce qui est de la DLT donc
c'est pour ça que notre association en
accompagnant et en participant avec
justement l'appel c'est ce qui va nous
permettre de pouvoir aller encore en
dehors donc moi je pense sincèrement que
ça c'est des choses que l'on peut faire
avec on va dire avec une bonne avancée
et puis après je crois qu'on faut
peut-être pas oublier on a quand même
certaines personnalités qui qui sortent
de trappe qui sont au niveau
international plus que connu donc on les
oublie très souvent mais trappe il y a
un véritable potentiel et je crois qu'on
nous envie ça alors maintenant faut le
faire exploser de manière positive
albertitus vous voulez réagir oui comme
j'ai l'habitude de le dire traape est
une des plus belles villes de France je
le dis parce que justement je complète
totalement ce par sa diversité et tout à
l'heure monsieur Larvi parlait de
passerelle de partage et moi j'ajouterai
partenariat aussi c'est-à-dire que il y
a le monde sportif et il y aura le monde
culturel de diversifier dans son apport
d'activité d'événement qui pourra
contribuer justement on parlait de une
fois que le sport est fini que doivent
faire ou que proposer aux enfants il y a
le fait que en faisant le sport en même
temps et nos associations qui ont
quelque chose à apporter de culturel de
diversifié ont la possibilité de
proposer en même temps il n'y aura pas
que le sport et puis après le sport
c'est fini mais dans le sport et à
travers la vie de tous les jours
apporter aussi la connaissance la
culture le partage parce que nous sommes
vraiment dans traape une toute une
diversité qui devons essayer de nous
connaître un peu mieux les uns les
autres et ce serait vraiment la gagner
si nous faisons tous un effort pour
partagerathan sor moi pour ma part c'est
vrai que l'idée de de Mustapha m'a
vraiment charmé parce que on s'était
interrogé sur cette question de de de de
contrôle enfin du moins essayer de
contrôler les actions des enfants savoir
comment interagir aussi avec les parents
parce que du pas uniquement s'occuper du
côté sportif mais essayer de suivre un
peu ce sportif il est fait de il est
traité de main de maître par
l'enseignant principal jaw Chua François
Gomis pour pas les citer Issam Rachedi
et Yann Burel et et j'en suis vraiment
fier de cette équipe là et aujourd'hui
on pour l'école taekwendo puisque c'est
c'est c'est le projet enfin c'est pour
septembre ça sera ce sera ce club là
l'école dans tout son sens c'est-à-dire
le on avait pensé à ce fameux carnet
pour pouvoir interagir avec les parents
avec les enfants si les parents avaient
un souci à l'école qui puisse nous faire
remonter l'info parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte qu'il y a des enfants qui
performaient au taondo et à l'école
catastrophe tant le comportement ou le
travail on a réussi avec nos petits
outils à régler certaines certaines
certaines
et on a était remercié par des
proviseurs ou des des instituteurs moi
voilà le travail il est mon travail est
fait je suis super content pour ça et je
me dis c'est à notre petite échelle
alors avec appel qu'est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire ça va être c'est
gigantesque on va pouvoir toucher des
millions de person enfin des millions
des milliers de personnes dans un
premier temps mais je pense que son
projet il y a de l'ambition mais c'est
vraiment c'est quelque chose de réel et
c'était un concevable pour moi de ne pas
le rejoindre dans sa démarche alors
c'est une association Mustapha Larbaoui
qui dit association dit demande de
subvention alors dans un contexte
généralisé que ce soit dans la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 an
nouvel ou plus largement il y a
restriction budgétaire alors comment
vous allez obtenir de l'argent pour
cette association pour voilà pour
mutualiser pour mettre peut-être des
personnes sur le terrain des médiateurs
ou autres je vais répondre à la question
et je réponds toujours aux questions on
a parler des chiffres j'ai répondu au
final et là pour le coup répondre vite
parce que av je vis simplement dire que
quels que soient les mots qu'on emploie
le flicage le contrôle et cetera à un
moment donné il y a un modèle qui existe
sur lequel moi je fais référence c'est
l'école l'école républicaine il y a pas
une école qui fait pas l'appel il y a
pas une école qui crée pas des
statistiques pour dire que mes enfants
sont venus aller à par exemple dans le
football Arnaud MBS tous les G du club
de foot les éducateurs du club ont des
statistiques pour suivre le nombre de
séances et a un moment donné quand le
nombre de séances est inférieur à la
moyenne ou est inférieur à un certain
chiffre c'est là qu'on va se poser des
questions donc j'ai pas peur peur des
chires j'ai pas peur des stades j'ai pas
peur appelons mettons les mots qu'on
veut contrôle flicage et cetera les
parents comprennent bien qu' un moment
donné ils sont placés dans des
associations des structures qui
comprennent que c'est très structuré et
que ça travaille beaucoup et que c'est
très on va dire performant et ces
statistiques là sont juste des
statistiques de performance des
statistiques qui qui correspondent à un
réel et c'est de ça que nous irons entre
guillemets les les les outils et et tout
ce dont on a parlé jusque-l juste une
parenthèse là-dessus euh vous m'avez
parlé des des problèmes d'argent c'est
vrai que par exemple laakaskiy a annoncé
que la compétence euh sport et culture
était optionnel et par définition
l'option é levé donc l'option elle est
optionnelle par définition l'option est
levée et aujourd'hui le club de foot
d'autres
associations se voi réduire leur budget
de 30 % pour certains pour arriver
demain à zéro alors là-dessus c'est une
option au moins ils prennent leur
responsabilité ils ont été élus et il
prennent leur responsabilité et que les
gens l'entendent j'aurais deux choses à
dire et ça c'est un appel également
j'appelle non seulement les gens à nous
rejoindre pour l'association mais de
façon citoyenne j'appelle aussi les gens
à voter puisque le vote est utile le
vote sert à quelque chose le vote
impacte que l'on vote ça c'est le
premier point en train de nous dire
qu'il fallait voter contre la major j'ai
pas dit qu'allait voter contre qui que
ce soit mais je dis qu'à un moment donné
tous ceux qui se plaignent je les
entends se plaignent n'ont pas forcément
votter donc c'est ça que je dis et appel
n'est pas fait contre les politiques
n'est pas fait contre ceux qui n'ont pas
voté n'est pas fait contre qui que ce
soit mais pour nos enfants alors si les
moyens diminu on va mutualiser des
choses on va faire en sorte d'avoir des
économies d'échelle les uns par rapport
aux autres ça c'est le premier point
donc il y a un vrai boulot pour faire en
sorte de mutualiser non seulement les
énergies les moyens mais également les
outils qu'on a chez nous pour éviter que
par exemple tout le monde achète son
véhicule que tout le monde achète sa
machine à lav que tout le monde utilise
je ne sais quoi comme outil pour
travailler il y a peut-être à regarder
l'économie on va dire une une économie
de partage puisqu'on parle de solidarité
il y a aussi ça et enfin au niveau des
subventions si j'avais un appel un autre
appel à faire c'est que je comprends
qu'on va y faire des économies
simplement les économies c'est sur tout
le monde et tout le monde de la même
façon j'aimerais qu'il y a un peu plus
de discernement à vouloir faire Mo- 30
tout le monde ou - 50 à tout le monde
quand je sais que par définition il y a
peut-être à mon avis un discernement à
faire parce qu'il y a pas que du sport
dans certaines associations mais il y a
la politique de la ville qui est
entraînée par ça et enfin pour terminer
parce qu''on parle de subvention
puisqu'on parle d'argent Paris qu'on
parle de moyens moi tout de suite après
de la guerre tout de suite après je pars
pour le dire je pars au Bristol pas pour
faire de la pub mais parce que c'est un
parter d'entrepreneurs qui sont des
entrepreneurs qui veulent se réunir dans
un cadre idylique pour y passer une
bonne soirée autour du vin autour de de
la bonne chair autour de d'un grand
restaurant et de grand chef simplement
ils sont aussi là pour rentendre si on a
des choses à leur proposer donc je je ne
fais pas je ne fais pas contre qui que
ce soit mais pour les enfants et si s'il
y a un faute de moyens alors on le dira
parce qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait un peu
plus de discernement et qu'on regarde un
peu mieux ce qui est fait parce que moi
je peux comprendre qu'on ve retirer à
des gens qui sont pas spécialement dans
le dans leur objet ou ou dans le cadre
pédagogique qu'on leur a bien voulu ou
qu'ils ont bien voulu dire qu'on regarde
mais avec discernement et enfin ces
gens-là qui payent déjà beaucoup ils
payent par leurs impôts sur les sociétés
qui payent beaucoup avec les charges
sociales les entreprises participent
énormément mais probablement qu'il y en
aura quelques-uns qui diront on a envie
de mettre un billet sur cette idée on a
envie de mettre une contribution sur sur
sur un territoire parce que
effectivement c'est sérieux parce que
comme le disait Benoin tout à l'heure
cette image est en train de se modifier
mais elle se modifie avec tout non non
simplement no nos espérances nos nos
capacités mais également ce qu'on
produit donc oui le mesena euh la
mutualisation des moyens et puis les
subventions mais appel est une
association qui n'est ni sportive ni
culturelle donc probablement qu'on fera
des dossiers parce que politique de la
ville est un objet entre guillemets qui
n'est pas sollicité totalement donc la
préfecture la ville mais c'est c'est pas
l'objet premier on arrive déjà à faire
des choses sans un centime on aura
besoin de d'imprimer ces carnet on aura
besoin d'outils il faudra aller chercher
quelques moyens on demandera uniquement
ce dont on a besoin on n' pas besoin
d'une caisse pleine et la regarder comme
certains et dire on a de l'argent et on
vit bien mais c'est don pour faire c car
not donc il y aura des il y aura des il
y aura un tableau de bord il y aura un
table de bord il y aura des objectifs il
y aura des moyens à y mettre qui seront
toujours proportionnés à nos Besin Besin
et à l'avancée de cette association il y
aura pas de gaspillage au contraire on
fera probablement encore mieux avec moi
mais avec de nouveaux acteurs puisquon a
les associations autour de la table il y
a un mot qu'on n pas encore prononcé
c'est la mairie euh alors quelles sont
les relations avec la mairie est-ce que
vous avez contactter on va laisser
d'abord nos invités répondre est-ce que
vous avez eu des contacts avec la mairie
est-ce que avec vos associations
respectives vous avez déjà essayé par
rapport au projet de muststapha
l'arbaoui de fédérer les associations
puisque pour information euh la mairie
euh actuel a décidé de mettre les les
associations au centre des animations
notamment pour la prochaine fête de
trappe donc une façon peut-être de
mettre les les les associations en avant
donord à priori lors de la fête de
trappe tous les ans les associations
sont au cœur de l'activité puisque ce
sont elles qui proposent les animations
ce sont elles qui tiennent les standes
donc a priori il y a pas eu grand
changement par rapport à ce qui se
faisait les années précédentes donc je
sais pas où est-ce que vous avez V
l'information qui fait que d'un seul
coup les associations sont centre de la
fête puisque ce sont les associations
qui sont les moteurs de cette fête
organisé par la mairie mais à part ça
organis organisé par la mairie mais faut
bien qu'il fasse quelque chose au-delà
de ça ce qui est intéressant dans le
projet d'appel c'est justement qu'on va
se soustraire totalement de l'aspect
politique des choses on a chacun nos
convictions on a chacun on a chacun n
mener mener nos campagne avec tel ou tel
parti ou même pas du tout euh et
pourquoi pas simplement on a tous le
même objectif qu'on soit de gauche de
droite du centreou d'ailleurs euh notre
ambition c'est de faire en sorte que
trappe soit une fille où on vit bien où
les gens sont épanouis heureux d'être
ensemble et c'est pas le rôle de la
mériie de fédérer les associations pour
laie va être toujours bloqué par
son par ce côté politique qui peut gêner
chacun lorsque le maire de gauche tient
un propos il sera toujours vu de façon
un petit peu plus avec un peu plus de de
d'éloignement par les personnes qui sont
un peu plus de tendance à droite et
inversement donc ce côté politique aura
toujours pour fonction de créer un biais
dans la compréhension des événements
avec appel on fait fille de politique on
est ensemble on est des citoyens de
trappe et on s'arrête à ça et avec ça on
va pouvoir construire quelque chose de
correct et on laisse tomber la politique
voilà jeanathan Sorel moi pour ma part
j'ai eu l'occasion à plusieurs reprises
notamment dans le montage de
l'association de discuter avec le le
maire adjoint l'irabet on a la jeunesse
au sport ouis exactement et on a eu un
très bon
contact peu importe en fait qu'il soit
de gauche ou droite le le principe est
le même c'est qu'on on est là pour les
enfants et j'ai j'ai
réussi à négocier avec lui à lui
demander une une subvention
exceptionnelle pour faire partir six
enfants des benjamins donc de de 8 à 10
ans en Turquie en championnat d'Europe
donc ça c'était une chose assez
exceptionnel donc VO de ce côté-là j'ai
pas de souci à priori maintenant c'est
vrai qu'effectivement on manque de
moyens et que je pense que comme l'a dit
Mustapha il va falloir aller les
chercher un peu partout que ça soit à la
mairie ou ailleurs s'il le faut dans le
privé albertitus oui et cette année
c'est exceptionnel quand même en parlant
de la fête de trappe parce que je suis
d'accord c'est les les associations sont
toujours partenair ont toujours été
sollicités mais cette année ce sont les
associations qui sont vraiment à
l'honneur euh parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'appel pour d'autres structures que les
associations de trappe c'est-à-dire que
contrairement à ce qui se fait
d'habitude contrairement à ce qui se
fait d'habitude et même sur scène il
aura des des artistes qui sont présentés
ou issus des associations de de trapppe
pour être un peu pour être un peu taquin
estce que je dirais que c'est moins cher
je je vais même dire que c'est gratuit
pour pour les les bénévoles qui vont se
manifester mais c'est mais en même temps
en parlant d'enfant je crois que nous
devons aussi sensibiliser et parler des
parents aussi en même temps ce n'est pas
simplement les les enfants qui nous
intéressent c'est que les parents
puissent voir l'objectif de ce que
propose l'association et puisse aussi
adhérer adhérer et participer activement
à tous les mouvements que nous allons
leur
proposer Mustapha on a souvent tendance
à se retourner en France je trouve pour
connaître un peu la culture d'autres
pays sur le plan politique et économique
on a souvent tendance à se retourner
vers l'état à se retourner vers les
politiques et en attendre probablement
beaucoup trop même si on pense qu'il en
a jamais assez de fait mais franchement
euh je l'ai proposé à l'OMS depuis 6 ans
l'OMS le fice municipal d'eSport je l'ai
présenté donc ce projet il a déjà 6 ans
cette notion non pas d'appel structuré
comme ça mais l'idée selon laquelle on
doit partager nos expériences on doit
communiquer on doit je l'ai proposé ce
Pass j'appelais ça le passeport à
l'époque puisque c'était un passe sport
à l'OMS c'est-à-dire dans l'ufice
municipal des sport au quun cas c'était
proposé il y a plus de 6 ans je l'ai
proposé aux responsables sportifs de la
ville de Trapp à main reprise l'idée est
géniale on va faire sauf qu'il ne se
passe rien donc je ne dis pas qu'il
n'aurait pas fait un jour c'est juste
que moi j'ai plus le temps d'attendre
parce que réellement je pense qu'il faut
aller vite donc oui Benoît amont est
informé et il m'a donné son sentiment
sur cette affaire il a même des
propositions à nous faire oui j'ai vu
Fourgous monsieur Fourgous Jean-Michel
Fourgous qui a été séduit par cette idée
et qui nous donnera probablement des
moyens également j'ai vu j'ai vu donc
j'ai discuté longuement avec Ali rab
cité tout à l'heure responsable des
sports j'ai vu également le responsable
Philippe j'ai oublié son nom responsable
de la culture ils ont tous reçu soit des
SMS bref des
informations tout est en transparence on
ne tombera pas dans l'écueil de c'est
quoi cette réunion est-ce que ce sont
des opposants je ne sais pas ce qu'il
pensent est-ce que ce sont des gens qui
vont bosser contre en tous les cas je je
m'opposeraiis à ce qu'on soit contre il
y a déjà des critiques apparemment bah
que les critiques se fassent après tout
je je je connais cette formule qui dit
que tout homme qui entreprend a contrel
lui systématiquement quelqu'un qui veut
faire la même chose quelqu'un qui veut
faire exactement son contraire mieux
l'énorme la quantité énorme d'une d'une
armée d'autant plus comment dire
bruillante qu'elle ne fait rien donc il
y avait rien et aujourd'hui on est déjà
en train de d'en parler on il y avait
rien et déjà elle est critiquée qu'on
travaille et qu'on nous juge sur nos
résultats sur les outils sur le
pragmatisme qu'on va y mettre parce que
je vous le dis hein ils sont partis pour
bosser
énormément énormément et que la critique
se fasse simplement sur des faits sur
des chiffres sur des réalités parce que
nous on va buser on va produire et ça va
se voir le reste ça pas été fait avant
on va le faire qui nous rejoigne qui
nous rejoigne moi personnellement j'ai
écrit à Monsieur le Maire pour avoir un
entretien sur le sujet est-ce que vous
avez une réponse à ce jour je le dis
devant les téléspectateurs à ce jour je
n'ai pas de réponse mais je sais bien
que l'occupation d' la merè n'est pas
simplement de s'occuper de d'une
association on l'aura et on le verra et
je sais qu'on peut discuter je sais
qu'on peut passer euh des moments avec
notre maire parce que vous le citiez
Monsieur le Maire qui nous recevra comme
il reçoit les associations et on va
avancer ensemble encore une fois c'est
pas fait contre c'est fait pour alors
les enfants oui parce que c'est l'objet
parce que ça passe par nos associations
mais il est évident que ce ne sont que
des adultes qui sont là pour encadrer
qui sont là pour confirmer ce qu'on dit
je vais vous demander messieur un
dernier mot de conclusion chacun on
arrive déjà au terme de de l'émission
très riche Sébastien Miguel peut-être il
nous dire aussi vraiment ce que vous
attendez de cette cette association de
l'appel juste une petite parenthèse sur
ce que vous venez de dire tout à l'heure
à savoir que pourquoi attendre une fête
de quartier ou une fin d'année pour
pouvoir bouger ou faire quelque chose ce
qui est dommage c'est que ça se fasse
qu'on qu'on pense que ça peut se faire à
ce moment-là moi je pense que c'est
toute l'année que ça peut se faire que
ça se fasse auprès des sportifs que ça
se passe auprès culturel que ça se passe
autrement même de notre côté au niveau
locataire nous derrière ce qu'on essaie
aussi de faire de de la même façon c'est
d'essayer de faire en sorte d'avoir un
mieux vivre pour ces locataires ça veut
dire enfants automatiquement ça veut
dire parents aussi de la même façon nous
depuis que l'on bouge depuis cette
explosion parce que si je devais en
parler un peu plus mais malheureusement
c'est pas le sujet euh il y a des prix
exponentiels où on fait partie des
moyennes les plus hautes en terme de
prix d'eau attrape auurisier plus
précisément ça ce sont des
problématiques c'est vrai mais en même
temps ça touche des enfants parce que la
consommation en elle-même est importante
ça touche le on va dire le le
portefeuille des enfants donc des
parents pardon et cell directement aussi
des parents donc c'est vrai que cet
appel en l'occurrence serait très
intéressant puisque derrière ça va on va
dire fédérer et nous donner de plus
grandes possibilités de pouvoir avancer
on va dire euh plus importante l'année
dernière quand on a quand on a manifesté
pardon on aurait bien aimé c'est vrai
avoir déjà cette cette ce côté fédéré le
côté fédération parce que ça nous aurait
permis de pouvoir on va dire encore plus
faire bouger les foules pour toutes les
problématiques qui entourent tout le
monde sans exception donc oui un grand
appel à tout le monde on va conclure sur
ça puisque le temps est parti voilà est
déjà terminé rapidement on viendra
surtout on reviendra le plus souvent
possible j'espère pour montrer les
outils dont on parle travail résultat
c'est de ça don je parle dont on parle
merci à eux parce qu'ils ont été merci à
tous les C d'avoir participé à cette
émission on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau 78 société à
18h30 en direct le thème le burnout
professionnel donc
attention n'hésitez pas à réagir sur le
Twitter de l'émission hashtag 78 société
bonne soirée à tous merci TV
[Musique]
merci